there are some republicans very few who
i still disagree with politically but
they have the recognition
and apparently the common sense to see
what the conservative right-wing
republican movement has been taken over
by in the united states
and to say these people are morons one
such person who literally used that word
is mitt romney and we're going to talk
about that a little bit later but first
we're going to take a tour through cpac
cpac the conservative political action
conference was in orlando florida over
the weekend and we already looked at
donald trump's speech which was
outrageous completely outrageous and
corrosive to democracy in every way but
i want to now just show you that
it was not an anomaly or an anomaly
whatever your preference is on the
pronunciation both are correct despite
me being criticized no matter which of
the two i use
no but in all seriousness um
it was it was just all completely
bonkers
here is radical republican congresswoman
lauren bober
saying she has already filed articles of
impeachment against biden kamala harris
and nancy pelosi
is that even true and if so like what
are they for she doesn't say solution
that i have put forward
the paperwork's already been filed she's
filed it already we haven't heard i
guess but she's filed it i have
introduced articles of impeachment to
impeach joe biden impeach kamala harris
get nancy pelosi the heck out of there
and save our country god bless you all
i'll see you next year this is a perfect
example of i'm going to say something
loudly
and people will clap and the words could
be anything right i mean she could have
just said i have just filed for sending
the first humans to jupiter's great eye
and people go yeah
okay i mean it's
whatever it's just it's just the the
tone
and speaking of tone
this is bizarre
remember larry kudlow trump's economic
advisor
he couldn't possibly be lower energy he
went up on stage
he speak speaking like someone a minute
before coming on stage just told him
someone had died close to him or
something lit this is
i guess this is supposed to inspire
people look at this
subpoena free and i got a new job
with fox business
so i hope you watch our show it's called
kudlow
please watch the show please
what's this
my show's pretty good here's the thing
we have adopted a mantra i have adopted
a mantra
for
the show yeah but for everything
and it's called save america
right that is what i want to talk to you
about today save america
[Applause]
okay uh the i don't i don't know who
appears more comatose uh the
the audience or
larry kudlow really a bundle of energy
as you can see uh then uh you may have
heard that papa john this is john
schnatter he's the guy from the papa
john's pizza company who was very much
against obamacare he said you know if if
i have to give everybody health care uh
it's gonna sort of cost me like 10 cents
a pizza and he was very very strongly
against it a conservative thought leader
you might be able to say
he suggests biden goaded putin into
invading ukraine in order to distract
from the so-called real issues which is
quite a quite a big brain conspiracy
theory
here we go administration vitamin c
totally incompetent or they do this
intentionally when you cut off our
pipeline and you open up brushes and you
give the guys 750 billion dollars looks
to me like it's pretty intentional but
what a great smokescreen what a great
distraction from all the real issues
here that affected americans so
um i think it's home screen i think it
was intentional yeah it was intentional
to create a smoke screen it says
conservative thought leader papa john
about uh what's happening geopolitically
and foreign relations exactly
then and this is where if you thought
this was crazy then it gets really crazy
the missouri state attorney general eric
schmidt says the constitution would soon
be replaced by the communist manifesto
if democrats got their way
they want to replace the declaration of
independence with a communist manifesto
right that's obviously untrue there are
essentially no communists in power in
the united states there are certainly
some social democrats
i guess there's a couple democratic
socialists although even they seem
confused as to whether they're really
democratic socialists people like bernie
and aoc i don't know that they're even
really democratic socialists so why
would the communist manifesto be put
anywhere doesn't make sense cpac speaker
charles herbster who's a candidate for
governor in nebraska
this is unbelievable he
the republicans over the weekend
realized pushing pushing putin is bad we
got to be pro ukraine they don't really
care one way or the other they just want
to do what sells
and so now they they've started saying
ukraine is the good guy and so charles
herbster asks the crowd to kneel and say
a prayer for ukraine and the camera cuts
to the audience and nobody's nobody
cares certainly nobody's kneeling but
it's it's wild they they just don't care
i'm gonna ask all of you to do a favor
even if it's a little uncomfortable yeah
you with your spouse is here
kneel down
and give a prayer
for what's taking place in ukraine right
first of all so far it's not clear
whether he wants them to pray for the
invasion to continue or for it to stop
it's sort of unclear from this so far
but let's keep going
they we they need our prayers
yeah that zelinski character
he's a hero
uh
mild very muted applause and certainly
nobody praying a couple of the panels
that they had
one of them is lock her up for real
referring of course to hillary clinton
this is beyond parody
ladies and gentlemen it's time for lock
her up for real
oh my god and then here's another very
very hard-hitting panel
ladies and gentlemen this is fire fouchy
a series of curated speeches
here very very carefully curated yeah
and then lastly here's todd starnes who
just openly anti-vaxx and this is not
against mandates this is just anti-vaxx
and you tell dr fauci to stick those
vaccines where the sun don't shine
god bless you all god bless america and
let's fight bouchy yep so um
these are very sick people but i want to
remind you and here's my my kind of last
thought on cpac um they are so good at
this the left doesn't have this type of
unity they don't have the willingness to
pour money into events like this and to
get everybody together to get everybody
on message the messages are idiotic fire
fouchy lock up hillary who hasn't been
charged with any crime
uh all the messages could not be more
absurd and destructive but they are so
good at organizing in this way and the
left is not
one of our sponsors is all form hands
down the easiest way to custom build
your own sofa you choose the premium
fabric you want you choose the sofa size
shape color even the color of the legs
you can customize every aspect of your
new sofa to make sure it's the perfect
fit for your home i got my first
all-form sofa a year ago i just got a
second one which is really exciting
these really are the sofas i would have
bought for my home even if all form was
not a sponsor you really can't beat the
quality the modern minimal design the
sofas are spill stain and scratch proof
you can buy one piece and start with
that and then buy more seats and
accessories to add on later shipping is
fast and free you get a hundred days to
decide if you want to keep the sofa it
comes with a forever warranty and you'll
get twenty percent off when you go to
all form dot com slash pacman the link
is right underneath this video